last month the world food program
announced that it can no longer provide
humanitarian aid to nearly one third of
the more than six million people who is
planning to feed this year in south
sudan the east african country has been
ravaged by flood and drought the
announcement leaves millions of lives
hanging in the balance cbs news deborah
patta has traveled across the country to
witness the devastating effects of its
hunger crisis
south sudan has been on the front line
of climate change battered by floods
and drought leaving millions of people
starving in this african nation then
came russia's war in ukraine and a
crisis became a catastrophe forcing the
world's food program to make drastic
cuts
we're heading off to the worst hit area
in south sudan with our children in
desperate need of aid and if they don't
get it they could be within days of
dying
famine stalks these villagers at a
makeshift clinic mothers bring their
emaciated babies to see nutritionist
mona shake
so we see she's already in the red
severely
i'm afraid you know
any child like that we are very close to
losing them
within days on the opposite side of the
country the greenery is deceptive this
village is actually drought-stricken
life was hard enough here long before
russia invaded ukraine with no rain for
over 18 months
nothing grows in this parched earth
it's so dry
and subsistence farmer nachopora lemuria
can no longer live off the land
sometimes i collect wild berries she
says to quiet the hunger her own mother
starved to death she's convinced she's
next
without food she warns you won't find me
alive next time you visit
she relies on rations from the world
food program but that lifeline has been
severed
this is it the last distribution for the
year after this
the community must survive on their own
we don't acting country director
adeyence
says the war in ukraine has sent food
and fuel costs soaring which means they
can feed less people so we've taken very
very difficult
decision to suspend assistance to 1.7
million people it's not that they're not
in need they are in need but we're
having to take from the hungry to feed
the starving the nearest market is over
50 miles away but prices are up nearly
100 percent
also has no food aid and can't afford to
eat
we heard they stopped the age he says
because the white people are at war
amidst the misery a burst of rain
for the moment it's a blessing
but lemuria knows it won't be enough to
grow anything
things are so bleak she can't afford to
clothe some of her children
her last bag of aid
will last barely two weeks
for cbs saturday morning debra para
capoeira south sudan
[Music]
i think that quote we had to take did
you write it down yeah we had to take
food from hungary to feed the starving i
think it is hard for so many of us to
even wrap our heads around and they've
been warning about it since the spring
that because they could see it coming
when the ukraine war began remember so
much wheat sunflower oil other grains
they're working furiously to try to
figure out a way to get it out because
the next harvest is coming they got to
empty the silos and if they don't do it
soon there's concern about political
instability across africa the middle
east asia where they rely so much on
that ukrainian grain well and the fact
is that it's going to get worse and you
see these families in these children and
what what options do they have next
not none
and it is a reminder i know we said this
every day during the pandemic that we
are all so interconnected and it's
thousands of miles away right this is
exactly what it is it's the domino
effect of everything and
thanks to debra pat and her team of
course for getting out there and doing
that for us yeah